bonjour à chevaucher merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors on l'a vu 1 6 milliard d'euros
pour le personnel soignant est ce que
c'est suffisant écoutez clairement il
faut le dire le contenu n'est pas 6
milliards uniquement pour le personnel
soignant des hôpitaux publics
vous savez qu'il ya plus de 900000
personnel soignant dans les hôpitaux du
caire à camiers affirmé secrétaire les
psychologues orthophonistes et ont
beaucoup beaucoup de monde donc
effectivement c'est une somme mais qu'il
ne correspond pas à l'ensemble des
personnels publics privés associatifs et
médico social
donc aujourd'hui c'est un geste scène
signal le signal est quand même
important mais il n'est pas à la hauteur
des attentes de l'ensemble café
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
monde et les impatients sont vives
puisque bulls avaient même avant que
vides on a eu une année très difficile
qui correspondait à la nécessité d'une
reconnaissance financière de personnel
très nuancé sa meilleure année intel et
soignants réclament une augmentation de
salaire vous l'avez dire bien avant la
crise
duco vitesse que vous trouvez ça dommage
justement qu'il ait fallu une crise
sanitaire pour enfin arriver à ce
chiffre est enfin augmenter le personnel
soignant
écoutez je vais vous dire dans la
chanter il ya toujours décrivent ça peut
être le co vite avec le flash avec la
canicule il est toujours des crises de
toute façon aujourd'hui il faut prendre
les problèmes en compte mais ça tombe
bien de savoir si le rendez vous est un
rendez vous marqué manqué et non pas un
rendez vous marqué il y aura d'autres
mobilisations d'autres manifestations et
bien entendu d'autres crises
alors le problème c'est qu'elle
personnel hospitalier peut être sûr à ne
sera pas aussi patient et les choix d un
risque d'être compliqué c'est à dire que
devant la cus kobe
on voit tout le monde a été rendez vous
public je dire on est fier de ce conflit
mais c'est aussi d'autres missions et je
suis aussi l'obtention façade nouvelle
sisa une nouvelle bague ou à une
canicule
je suis très inquiète alors aujourd'hui
le gouvernement va dévoiler le coût des
différentes mesures de revalorisation
envisagé qu'est ce que vous en attendez
bah écoutez moi je suis médecin
aujourd'hui à la tête de l'organisation
joueurs présents je ne suis pas là cadre
des négociations ce matin puisqu'il y à
le laisser le personnel non médical
donc je leur fais confiance je ne fais
que nous n'abordons 1 2 pour leur équipe
on fonctionne ensemble les médecins avec
et paramédicaux mais si les médecins qui
présente le plateau technique des
hôpitaux ne sont pas valorisées nous on
doit avoir notre science de négociations
lundi prochain sachez que depuis
quelques semaines nous mais bon les
calendriers ni chiffrage vite quelques
mesures d'organisation interne dont nous
avions man soit entendu parler sur notre
valorisation niveau musical n'intervient
pas dans le même temps que celle du
personnel non médical
là les médecins risquent de casser
rieuse manquons disons patience et
confiance dans le gouvernement et donc
je peux vous dire qu'ils font preuve
certainement deux mois de mobilisations
cadre de nouvelles combines j'espère
qu'elle se met à le gouvernement sera au
rendez vous qui va peut-être disons que
c'est une négociation - donc il ya des
propositions il ya une évolution dans
les propositions et dans le le cadrage
que les données
j'espère que ce matin quelque chose vont
aboutir et qui vont nous permettre lundi
de pouvoir rebondir sur une autre
négociation celle des médecins mais
aujourd'hui n'aboutissent pas vraiment
dans le sens que vous souhaitez est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à voir d'autres
danses manifestation d'autres d'autres
mouvements dans les semaines à venir du
personnel soignant et des et des
médecins je le regrette je le
regretterai les probablement quelques oh
là où nous avons un moment historique
elle moment historique anglais
il on a montré nos difficultés
démographiques des postes vacants dans
tout dans tous les métiers des
difficultés d'organisation des hôpitaux
les expédients médecins et nos
médecins il gouvernement n'est pas au
rendez vous là effectivement on peut
craindre les dès mardi prochain une
nouvelle mobilisation
merci beaucoup rachel bocher d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl on rappelle
que vous êtes présidente de
l'intersyndicat national des praticiens
hospitaliers merci beaucoup